buona sera io sono di rho assimo
macchine vengono dalla città
notoriamente più vivaci l'italia da
fermo fermo nome che non gli rende
giustizia e accettasse dovrebbe chiama
paralisi sinceramente molti mi hanno
chiesto ma come era fermo durante
lockdown uguale a prima
comunque sapete fermo ascoli sono due
città bellissime di questa bellissima
regione che le marche le nostre marche
questa regione del centro dove al centro
ci s finirono un po poco soprattutto il
cinema hanno fatto prima benvenuti al
sud dopo benvenuti al nord del centro ma
non va a morì ammazzato niente però
signori oggi pomeriggio insomma qui non
vi voglio parlare della mia città né
tantomeno delle marche perché voi sapete
io faccio il comico cioè io sono un
comico però voglio essere sincero voglio
fare una premessa chiara io non è che un
giorno proprio mi sono alzato la mattina
e ho deciso le fa il comico no io scemo
ci sono nato e stato un dono di dio e
mio questo e adesso ve lo spiego vi
scrivo anche come a me l'umorismo ma
abbia salvato veramente la vita allora
io vengo da una famiglia molto numerosa
io sono l'ultimo di sette figli gioco
aumentando i fratelli che debbo conosce
ancora il primo questo nel vero senso
della parola
mio padre mi madre ha fatto sette figlie
totalmente fertili dei giovani
soprattutto mi padre che sul petto
invece reperire crescevo all'insalata
quando passavano i giri fiori dei fiori
che se bollina uno da solo però la mia
famiglia una storia molto particolare un
certo punto c'è stata un lutto il lutto
è importante il mio primo fratello si
chiamava massimo è morto 17 anni
per un problema al cuore quindi capite
mio padre mia madre erano sei figli il
primo di questi sei figli muore c'è
stata insomma una tragedia forte tant'è
che mi madre soprattutto cade in una
depressione molto forte e per i due anni
successivi della morte di mio fratello
massimo stava sul letto non si alzava
allora certo punto mi padre adorno stato
geniale già avuto un'idea veramente
geniale una sera zitto zitto entrato in
camera s'è messo a letto come madre così
fischiettando come se non fosse stesse
per succedere niente senza dirglielo
la messa incinta dopo un po di tempo mi
madre ma mio padre fa adorno ma sto
incinta babbo la guardate detto
scherzetto e sono nato io quindi
semifreddo il mio fratello non fosse
morto io non sarei mai nato
ditemi se questo non è uno scherzo la
natura
quando ho capito adesso è nato per
scherzo per gioco ho deciso di vivere la
mia vita in allegria a portà questa
allegria più persone possibile per
questo come mi piace far ridere la gente
soprattutto mi madre
tra le altre cose mi male ma partorito e
la tenera età di 47 anni e ancora oggi
in belgio il fatto che non è sembrata
prima e menopausa e io le chiedevo ai
miei fratelli ma come era massimo mamma
quando ho scoperto insomma ds insomma
incinta dice guarda mamma finiti
piangere per la morte del mio fratello
massimo iniziò a piangere per la nascita
mia e io ogni volta che l'incontro
animali e lo dico sempre mamma ma come
era massimo lei mi guarda con gli occhi
lucidi e mi dice guarda per ma massimo
era bravo a scuola era bravo con gli
amici era bravo a casa di gomma un po
come me dice veli per ma non tutte le
ciambelle riescono con il buco
tu sei uscito dal buco è che attorno non
c'è niente per massimo e questa cosa
avesse nato un po per scherzo per
giocare cabina essere una dopo la morte
amy fratello un po dentro
entro dentro di me un po risuonavano
delle domande soprattutto nel periodo
dello sviluppo che tra l'altro io credo
questo sviluppo per me non è mai finito
perché sennò ancora tante parti dentro
la testa mia se devono finire sviluppa
mamme ponevo delle domande importanti
tipo chi sono dove vado a chi scrocco un
passaggio ma anche domande più
esistenziali tipo ma so più piero o so
più massimo posso piero massimo perché
avevo un po d'angoscia dentro di me
sentivo fortemente la tragedia della
morte del mio fratello piero ma
contemporaneamente sentivo fortemente la
commedia della vita del piero e queste
due cose non andavano tanto d'accordo
allora tu sei in quel periodo in cui non
riesce a darti delle risposte
ti affidi e degli esperti a chi ne sa
più di te e io vi ricordo che conobbi il
mio psicologo iniziai a frequentare mio
psicologo e lo conobbi a scuola alle
superiori allo scientifico e lo conobbi
proprio bene il mio psicologo
scientifico perché non ho fatto come
tutti tutti quanti insomma lo
scientifico in cinque anni no io l'ho
fatto in 7 proprio volevo capi bene
perché io ci andava un po poco a scuola
sala govi java infatti oggi quando mi
chiedono le fa una firma non faccio la
mia ma quella di mamma io che ho fatto
che aveva messo fatto e inizia questo
percorso di terapia su queste domande
esistenziali col mio psicologo però non
è soffermato gli ho voluto indagare
ancora di più ho fatto yoga reiki
costellazioni familiari quelli mano
proprio illuminato poi ritorna e ancora
dal mio psicologo e questo percorso vi
dico che è durato più o meno 10 12 anni
fino a quando quando sono ritornato al
mio psicologo voglio psicologo ma
guardate m web per massimo di non ne
posso più fa terapia perché io e te
siamo diventati amici e poi sinceramente
mi fanno pena perché vedo che non
capisci tanto però mi lascio con un
consiglio di cui ti consiglio di trovare
una ragazza una compagna una fidanzata
una moglie che faccia la psicologa mi
ricordo una sera stavo in discoteca
ballava un certo punto credo che una mi
guardava io lo guardavo le guardavo
certo punto mi faccio coraggio e faccio
ciao i nostri sguardi si sono incrociati
che faccio dà la precedenza per faccio
la vergata
se messe arride come a voi poi tra un
ballo e un altro tra un cocktail e un
altro già tu non ti faccio una scusa tu
che il lavoro fai
mi guarda e mi dice faccia la psicologa
ma è passato tutta la vita davanti
dico forse questa è la persona adatta a
me e abbiamo iniziato a frequentarci
sinceramente la relazione è stata un po
difficile all'inizio perché lei in
maniera subdola e faccia ritest il primo
test che m'ha fatto quello del roush sa
che quello che avete presente quelle che
vedi le figure e io vedo la gnocca
dappertutto qualche ci vedi a chiudere
un tramezzino di poi che ci vedi è qui
vedi un tramezzino torno carciofini di
qua che ci vede o quella terza figura
sembrava proprio la gnocca dico guarda
scusa ma mi sembra la gnocca di giò
finalmente il test di rorschach mette
proprio in relazione lio con la
sessualità
tu sei un uomo tutti gli uomini pensano
al sesso mio dove di langa fin
dall'inizio di kobe è pertanto poco
tu pensa che io pensavo la gnocca prima
ancora che tu arrivassi a fame il test
per come sono fatto io
un altro giorno passeggiavamo
tranquillamente lungomare un certo
pubblica della borsa della borsa esce
fuori una cartellina e sulla cartellina
gialla scritto test da fare a piero
massimo il cui il quoziente intellettivo
dicono speriamo di no perché che era
successo qualche giorno prima avevo
letto un articolo su focus junior che io
compro sempre perché capisco tutto di un
professore dell'università americana il
massachusetts che sosteneva questa tesi
diceva i secondogeniti sono meno
intelligenti dei primogeniti
io ho fatto un conto
essendo l'ultimo dei sette figli e non
era rimasto niente praticamente vado a
casa mi scarico il test mi prendo anche
due filetti debitrici per la memoria
melo somministra ea malapena e raggiunto
la sufficienza
immagina se non copiamo che figuraccia
che facevo e però la storia è andata
avanti e un certo punto lei mi chiese
danda convive appena mamma del maghetto
della convivente sono subito la mia
madre
gli ho detto guarda ma cristiano la mia
compagna maria turbolenta convive vuoi
vieni pure tu mamma ma guardando mai
detto guarda io con la compagnia ci
convive volentieri ma si istituì non
vengo e siamo andati a combina insieme
noi siamo andati e convivenze e mesta
relazione andata avanti tant'è che
adesso ci abbiamo anche due figli
insomma piccolini molto belli eccetera
eccetera
però io ancora mi ponevo delle domande
dentro no chiaro che volevo fare
qualcosa con quello fa il comico
sì perché faccio il comico non so chi è
soggetto a andato via ha fatto
interferenza di maria un attimo
io ho messo chiesto perché volevo fa il
comicon o in un altro tipo di lavoro
tipo che ne so l'idraulico
l'elettricista oppure in questo periodo
vende le mascherine che avrei fatto
sicuramente il sacco dei soldi no invece
campa questo del mestiere e poi è
arrivato il lock down ancora con tutte
queste domande non si diceva durante il
lock down ne saremmo usciti migliori
io farei una foto secondo me c'è stato
qualche problema a un certo punto no
però io dopo il log downs uscito
migliore sapete perché perché io ho dato
il peggio di me
infatti la mia compagna psicologo grande
polo vita a una ma tirando fuori tutte
le sindromi alla fine del primo mesi ma
è tutto il cielo e complesso di edipo
che non è un gruppo che fa musica
psicologica alla fine del secondo mese
mi ha detto guarda tu c'hai la sindrome
narcisistica di personalità nel senso
che io un po messo per valuto giacché
non valuto proprio possibilità né andare
a lavorare sinceramente alla fine del
terzo mese mi ha detto guarda tu c'hai
la sindrome di personalità multipla
praticamente che non so solo io ma
dentro di me ne siamo in tanti e neanche
uno ci voglia di lavorare alla fine del
quarto mese metto tutte le complesse
cassazione ma questo già lo sapevo
perché eravamo in due a dare cielo
figlio il gatto quindi stavo tranquillo
insomma però io in tutto questo periodo
di ricerca
l'ho raccontato che è durato dai 10 ai
12 anni più o meno alla fine di questo
periodo se uscito fuori che era molto
forte di chi euro della mia identità e
della mia originalità perché avevo
capito che finalmente aero piero massimo
perché avevo fatto pace con la tragedia
di massimo e la tragedia della morte del
mio fratello massimo l'avevo fatta un po
fidanzata con la commedia di piero e mi
sentivo forte mi sentivo originale e poi
a un certo punto ho capito che potevo
fare il comico che potevo campa proprio
da questo perché io andavo dallo
psicologo e raccontavo le mie tragedie e
a fine seduta e gli pagavo poi andavo
sul palco racconta volo i miei tre cd e
a fine serata me pagavano perché la
gomma e della tragedia su due facce
diverse e opposte della stessa medaglia
basta capire dove vogliamo vederle o
l'una o l'altra
e poi ho capito che l'unica storia che
posso raccontare realtà è l'unica che
conosco bene e la mia certo tevis cava
devi conoscerla bene ma l'unica io vi
posso raccontare è la mia la conosco
molto bene l'altro giorno dall'altro
voglio fare una citazione stavo bevendo
un caffè al bar del triangolo prende una
bustina dello zucchero la giro c'era una
citazione di arkin polster io non
conosco non credo ne sia marchigiano
sinceramente dice ogni vita merita un
romanzo è davvero perché ognuno di noi
c'è una vita bellissima da poter
racconta certo oggi potrei raccontarvi
che che ne so la storia de mario
tarquini un amico mio che ha fatto liti
diventato periodo l'ingegnere ha preso
una laurea ingegneria e una psicologia e
un in filosofia e mostra fuori di testa
perché lo studio quando è troppo fa male
oppure la vita dissesto terribili un
amico mio sesto che tra l'altro c'est
come me l'ultimo sette figli ma lui
hanno chiamato sesto perché prima non
hanno chiamato 0
ma non sarebbe interessante non sarebbe
interessante come la la vita che come la
storia della vita mia perché io ho
capito che se mio fratello non fosse
morto e non sarei mai nato quindi a me
l'umorismo ma salvato la vita perché
sono riuscito a ridere della mia
tragedia e l'umorismo stato un costante
per me perché a un certo punto appunto
come soggetto per fortuna che faccio il
comico perché se non facciamo questo
mestiere a quest'ora o ero depresso o
era un drogato
sicuramente non avrei fatto nè
l'elettricista né tantomento nel
idraulico e non ha avuto la genialata e
chopin delle mascherine prima dell'hog
down
poi a un certo punto mi sono reso conto
che a me l'umorismo francia sta bene
perché io sì faccio ri degli altri ma io
sono uno che ride tantissimo io l'ho col
cerco continuamente l'umorismo e tu
quando ridi ed aiuta a livello fisico
chimico si smuove l'intestino alquanto
che smuove l'intestino tu la mattina e
va poiché in a meraviglia quindi noi
possiamo cercato nelle cose ma se una
mattina caffè sigaretta e al bagno stai
benissimo è proprio perfetto perfetto e
poi ho capito
a un certo punto la cosa più importante
è l'umorismo che ma proprio illuminato
che che quando noi ridiamo in realtà
stiamo dicendo che siamo vivi e il mio
maestro domenico lannutti maletto il
comico è quello che sceglie di scivolare
sulla buccia di banana
cioè io sto qui vi racconto le mie
tragedie perché ci avete presente no la
classifica e che dell'uomo che scivola
sulla buccia di banana quello scivolai
perché fate ride the ma quello si è
fatto male
perché ridiamo vediamo per demonizzare
la più grande paura che abbiamo è quella
della morte nel momento in cui io rido
in realtà mi sto dicendo sono vivo
perché quando vedo che quello scivola
sulla buccia di banana
oltre a lisa del cervello pensa non è
successo a me ma è successo lui e quindi
io soffrivo che sarà capitato che vede
il comico che gioco con quelli in prima
fila no gioco in prima fila e tutti
ridono perché non tocca gli attimi dopo
quelle in prima fila
io per di adesso non mi sono affacciato
non ho visto che c'è in prima fila o no
però di solito in prima fila ci sono i
migliori c'è stato un proviamo al
botteghino evidentemente no sennò non si
spiega vedete tutti qual è l esatto
vedete tutti quanti voi ridete perché
non succede poi ma succede a loro questa
è una tecnica molto facile da utilizzare
anzi diffidate dai comici che giocano
sempre con quelli che stanno in prima
fila perché è molto facile far ridere
così io per fortuna oggi in un bacio
spettacolo perché se nostra tecnica
l'avrei utilizzata è guardandole negli
occhi sinceramente ma noi ridiamo per
demonizzare la più grande paura che
abbiamo è quella della morte e quindi io
quello che posso invita oggi oltre a
conoscere bene le vostre tragedie
renderle comiche perché sono due facce
opposte alla stessa medaglia
abbiamo imparato ed è sempre il
bicchiere mezzo pieno anche perché
quello mezzo già ce lo siamo bevuti
quindi insomma siamo già felici e
contenti ma di cercarlo l'umorismo di
cercarlo dell'umorismo e di cercare lo
stesso tempo di essere noi quelli che
scivola sulla buccia di banana di essere
un po ridicoli perché diciamoci la
verità noi ci concediamo il colle
leggiamo la possibilità di essere
ridicoli in pochissime situazioni
delicate 3 quando siamo con gli amici
stretti con i quelli che siamo i quali
abbiamo che ci siamo cresciuti insieme
no allora c'era una sorta di fratellanza
che siamo molto vicini non ci
vergogniamo di fa delle cavolate oppure
quando siamo ubriachi
no quando siamo prix a chi ogni freno
inibitorio pavia e quindi facciamo delle
figuracce che ne basterebbero la metà e
poi quando stiamo di fronte i bambini
quando siamo di fronte i bambini diamo
il peggio di noi
perché pensiamo che i bambini sono
cretini e turisti bambini che ti guarda
e dentro del loro pensano non voglio
diventare come lui sinceramente invece
no lo dovremmo cercare più l'umorismo
perché se lui ricercati c'è lui
cerchiamo ci aiuta io cercandolo a me ma
salvato la vita perché appunto come ho
detto ho capito essere nato per gioco
per scherzo e quindi ho deciso di vivere
la mia milita in allegria perché ho
capito che per me la vita è stato un
regalo e regali come so so belli perché
non sai quello che c'è dentro pieno dei
colori pieno di sorprese ma soprattutto
il regalo non l'hai pagato e per ognuno
di noi la vita è un regalo perché
nessuno di noi decide di venire al mondo
neanche chi ci concepisce decide che
saremmo noi terremo al mondo per ognuno
di noi la vita un regalo perché c'è chi
è figlio della scelta consapevole
cerchio figlio di una notte del sesso
d'amore fugace cech è figlia della
provetta ciò che è finito in parte del
pativo rotto ma nessuno di noi dice di
venire al mondo tutti noi nasciamo per
uno scherzo la natura quindi di nasce
per gioco non può che vivere in allegria
e se vi cercate dentro veramente dentro
trovate che l'umorismo pieno nella mia
vita io ho trovato delle cose
incredibili tra l'altro la follia
all'umorismo lollo ce l'avevo proprio
vicino a casa ho detto io vengo da fermo
e abito a fermo in via dante zeppilli è
famoso perché invece zeppilli c'era il
manicomio casa mia di stava 50 pasti
esatte al cancello del manicomio e ne
sono stato abituato parla con i matti
quelli più tranquilli quelli che
potevano uscire quelli insomma che ci
hanno scritto sulla carta la voce segni
particolari la parola pazzia
poi fece valore di 180 non so se la
conoscete la legge basaglia chiusero i
manicomi invitante zeppilli fu una festa
tutti erano felicissimi ma soprattutto
liberi un giorno però io ho voluto fa
una ricerca perché io mi ricordo che nel
1996 l'anno in cui il manicomio e tanti
zeppilli affermo fu chiuso dentro
c'erano 60 matti sapere che fine hanno
fatto
20 si trovano a sassatelli ricovero per
anziani 20 alla comunità di capodarco
per disabili 17 alla comunità san
girolamo per malati di mente quelli
gravi due sono morti e uno
si sa che fine abbia fatto
grazie
[Applauso]